what's been the most consistent way for
you in terms of Landing clients
ultimately it's about persistence um and
it's about approaching a client from
several different angles when you're
going into a client you want to make
sure that you understand the
organizational structure you know who
your I guess you could say your
low-level decision makers are and
ultimately who's the guy that's signing
off their budget that might be a manager
a development manager a test manager and
then who's above that and what you want
to do is you obviously just want to
network around them you don't want to be
salesy with your approach but you've got
to remember that they are not committed
to that client forever they at some
point will be searching for a job and
they might want to know about rates in
the market or who's hiring so have a
chat with them about that and then once
you've given them something ask them a
bit about hey look I actually got a lead
says it was using this Tech can you help
me out or you know how about let's meet
and when you meet them can you ask them
to draw you out an or structure